[Music]
hello there fort nightmares 2021 has
begun fortnite is going through its
usual spooky seasonal change and with it
comes a bunch of secrets to find from
upcoming quests to story beats we can
try to predict please think about using
code adamaru for all your purchases
around this spooky time of year and see
your butt down for five minutes and
let's break down what's new in the world
of map changes
[Music]
like we could start anywhere other than
the new poi at the center of the island
for a month or more we'd watch the cubes
roll around seemingly aimlessly but it
was all leading to this point yesterday
an army of cubes surrounded goldy blocks
and today it all makes sense
the queen has arrived and currently sits
in a sphere above her kingdom of cubes
there's a few nods to the history of
fortnite here we should uncover remember
back when loot lake was turned into a
springboard that has been replicated in
this world and should you look closely
at the queen you'll see she is holding a
cube
think back to where we've seen a guy
floating in the air in a sphere holding
a bit of a cube all the way back in
chapter one and the emergence of the ice
king he did the exact same thing as the
queen held in a sphere summoning
something with a shard of cube energy
sadly back then it was morphines and
zombies and everyone was a little butt
hurt about the island becoming snow
covered from a law point of view we now
are able to link those two events and
hopefully once this is over the ice king
won't be a throwaway character and he'll
have some importance one more week until
we see what the queen has installed i
mean apart from the caretakers another
easter egg to find in this update is the
butterfly a rift butterfly we've seen so
many times in our history jonesy became
one the last time we saw him and this is
also a call back to the first time we
ever met a rift butterfly we slowly made
contact with one being very gentle well
the queen the queen doesn't feel the
same way that butterfly is no more
before we move on can we just spend a
moment listening to the queen laughs
goosebumps halloween may be a little
further away but it's already making its
mark on the fortnite island first the
return of the jump scare zombies in
random objects around the world the
first one i encountered lived in a
fridge the battle bus had its annual
update too with music and the lobby
screen is all spooky to get you in the
mindset of ghosts and ghouls halloween
is slowly kicking off with some homes in
town pois putting up their decorations
and getting in the spoopy vibes after
seeing the trailer i ran to pleasant
park i couldn't wait to see the new
musical stage
but alas either that is only in the
trailers for advertising purposes or
hopefully that will be part of next
week's update a stage like the one we
had at the beach last season maybe it
will build over time this week anyway in
the meantime there are things to see at
pleasant park right now the battle bus
inflatables the gravestones the witches
it's all coming back and where do the
locals get this stuff from at none other
than another forgotten location the
heibu star a few years ago it moved over
to the viking ship and it's there once
again right now in game most things are
set up like they were last season it's
packed in here there are a few key
changes mainly to the skin statues in
the lobby area they've been updated to
be more recent skins and the best thing
about being here is the return of a meme
strat replacing the statues and standing
as still as you can waiting to kill an
unsuspecting player by the way if you do
use that strat and hide here let me see
it tag me on twitter please here's
something very cool to look out for a
year ago a subtle easter egg was
revealed the ghostbuster car was hidden
under tarp down at camp cod striking it
made the sirens give off that wailing
sound just like the movies the
ghostbusters are coming back this year
and thanks to a trick with the replay
file we can spot this it's a ghost
catching device used by the ghostbusters
these traps are around the island i've
seen one at retail row and at craggy
cliffs so far not only is this cool
having a ghostbuster crossover but this
time we have challenges to capture
ghosts something completely new for this
game around these spots you will find
floating objects in your replay files
and i have no idea what they are for are
they part of the ghostbuster questline
or is this something completely
different oh and as i'm recording this
that event went live you have one week
happy ghostbusting everyone
some areas of the map have not been
updated like you may be expecting the
tiny chair and teddy are still the exact
same as they were last week and all the
gnomes are frozen in time about to make
their escape oh and this is a good time
to bring up a bunch of gnomes i missed
last week if you'd like to see more of
these cute buggers get your butt down to
the cabin in the woods and by the back
door here they are packed up ready to
leave this island forever little do they
know they can't escape none of us can
whilst looking around some strange
things can be spotted there's loads
going on at craggy clips while here
you'll see what looks like footprints
likely those of the new caretaker npc
these can be found all over the island
in sets of four check this one a
mysterious ritual site has been found
over by the tiny chair and it's possible
to get close enough to this kneeling
altar and you'll see an urn donned with
purple cube rooms this looks important
i'll be certain to keep an eye on it if
we are deciphering these rooms with urns
and tablets then maybe we will someday
understand the mysterious alphabet on
all those cubes and finally we can push
for answers that means so get in the
game and do your challenges we've got
lots to uncover so much law
[Music]
over to sloan now and only seven days
ago we looked at the possibility that
sloan the big bad guy from last season
was on her way to put right what went
wrong she's slowly been going around the
map trying to get some alien tech to a
location but we don't know the location
we all hoped it may be the redacted
bunker and this week she is one step
closer she's gone through retail row
she's unbelievably close to getting
answers for us or let's be serious
she'll likely drive straight past or
maybe she'll go up the mountain and live
in the snow for a while come back in
seven more days let's uncover what the
heck is going on and another reminder
there is another truck which the isle
use to move things over at holly hedges
the first truck still sits there dormant
ready to go it's got alien tech it's got
plants all over the back but it's just
that there maybe sloane will be coming
back to escort this one too
time will tell surprisingly the biggest
update this week is actually in another
game mode party royale i'll admit i
don't usually visit this place unless a
movie has been broadcast but wow if you
want to check out some halloween updates
this is the place to go as this mode
isn't my jam i'll just say have a look
if this is your kind of thing one thing
i wanted to ask you guys the new ltm in
this there are receivers or antennas of
some sort with this purple glow are
these just here for a one-off or do you
think they have a bigger part in the
story good luck beating the final boss
so there we have it how did i do did you
notice anything that i didn't please
comment below and i'll try my best to
reply here's a bunch of legends i talked
to this week in my twitter dms slide on
in sometime i'm adam you're awesome i'll
see you next time
[Music]
okay those who don't watch to the end
have gone i was hoping to talk to you
for a sec i'm looking to know what kind
of fortnite content you'd like me to
make i'll never be a daily youtuber but
i would like to improve what i do and
make more fortnite videos and i'm
thinking about going back into law again
is that something you'd be up for and
also that with the dc fortnite crossover
series continuing i'm thinking of
breaking that story down too any advice
on content you'd like me to make please
let me know in the comments i'll do my
best to read it and reply and try and
learn from it so thank you very much for
your time appreciate you taking a sec
out and i'll see you next time